[Music]
when i started working at
marvel i asked stanley how do you create
the perfect marvel character
he said imagine spider-man
it's just a red and blue suit jumping
off a building but tell me who he is
tell me what his problems are and now
when he flies off that building
we're in that suit
every moment along the way the superhero
has offered us a language to think about
our personal identities
who are you who do you want to be
my father did not like bullies comic
books for the vehicle to protect people
what a powerful image the black panther
story is this idea of an
untouched black space it brought me to
tears almost instantaneously
it wasn't pretend to me it was real it
was like you can tell stories about
yourself
i transformed into the most powerful
entity in the hip-hop
universe there was a time when asian
people in comics were colored yellow
i would just say hey maybe it's time we
stop doing that
women are drawn with nail marks of
toughness being a woman is different
than that
the question is what you do from those
mistakes you learn from them
i had no idea that i was the first
african-american writer in modern comics
she is just as good as the boys being a
gay youth
comic's a great place to hide for the
first time we kind of felt like we were
part of the story
we developed a completely new voice i
love it
you look at any great marvel story i
don't care who the character is
what the team is it's always a great
story about the person
behind the mask
[Music]
you